-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Hank Azaria.
Now, we've been talking about
how you've been doing this
a long time.
You do not have --
-A very long time.
-Very long time.
-I'm very tired.
-You've accomplished --
[ Light laughter ]
It's amazing you have
the energy to even be here.
-It is.
-Based on how long you've been
doing this.
-Yeah, let's move it along
because --
[ Laughter ]
-You don't have to audition
anymore, but you did --
and I think this is very helpful
for actors --
you had an ice breaker
in the audition setting.
-[ Laughs ] You've done
your research, sir.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
Never went well, though,
my "ice breaker."
-Oh, that's good.
So this is a cautionary tale.
-Well, I was mentioning earlier,
you know,
the absurdity of shooting.
The whole thing
is kind of crazy.
And, so, often you go into
auditions and they'll say --
you know, there'll be
the producers and the director
and people, and say,
"Any questions?
Do you have any questions?"
Meaning about the script
or the character.
And I would say,
"Yeah, um, so,
I'm supposed to pretend
I'm this guy?"
[ Laughter ]
And they would look at me and
they'd go, "Yeah. Yeah."
And I'd say, "And you're
going to point a camera at it,
but I'm supposed to pretend
I don't notice that?"
[ Laughter ]
And they would go, "Yeah."
And I would like at them like
they were insane and go, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Listen, that did much better
than it ever did in the room.
-Right, right.
Well, that's nice.
We're completing the circle
here.
-They would just --
they would look terrified
and answer earnestly, "Yes,
no, that's right. Yes, yes."
And then years later,
when I became a producer
and auditioned a lot of people,
I realized that
actors are often quite crazy.
-Yeah.
-So they might actually --
-They've heard other versions
of that, probably.
-Oh, you don't know
that somebody is not having
some kind of psychotic break
in front of you.
And need to be reminded that,
yes, the camera is going to be
there, yeah.
-What about -- this is amazing.
34 -- 34th season
of "The Simpsons."
[ Cheer and applause ]
-Yeah, I mean --
-Yeah.
-Well currently, 34 is airing.
We're currently making 35.
But who is counting except
for my business manager.
-Right, exactly.
And now how -- how much of
your time is now spent --
and because, again, you do
so many voices on the show --
-Yeah.
-Is it -- have you become
so efficient that you don't have
to work as many hours doing it?
Or is it exactly
as much time as --
-[As Moe] I'm going to answer
as Moe, just to --
-Okay, great, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just 'cause I feel like it.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I don't -- I barely work,
like, three minutes.
You know, they show me
the thing, I say the thing,
and then they send a check,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
You know.
-There you go. Nice and easy.
-[As Comic Book Guy] Sometimes
Comic Book Guy gets involved.
He says a few things.
Thank you for acknowledging me.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, do you get a little
excited when a new one
comes up, when they come --
I mean --
-[Normally] It's rare.
-Yeah, at this point,
I mean, I feel like they don't
want to overwork you.
There's probably some labor laws
involved of getting --
-I doubt it.
-Yeah.
-No, like, I -- you know,
Jim Brockmire is a guy
that I did on a TV show.
"Brockmire" is a show I did
for a while.
And he has now found his way
into the show a little bit.
-Oh, they -- he's found his way
into the -- that's wonderful.
-Yeah. I just played a --
some kind of a salesman.
I don't remember what --
a car salesman.
And I said, "Ah, let's go with
Jim Brockmire for this one."
[ Light laughter ]
So, yeah, but they're --
all the voices are, you know,
relatives or teachers.
-Yeah.
-People I grew up with.
-I mean, at what point did
everybody in
your life realize, "Oh, no"?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I've had --
there was a guy --
[As Nat ]I did this character on
"Mad About You"
called Nat the dog Walker.
And he talked like this.
Hey, how you doin' here?
What's goin' on?
[Normally] And he was based on
a guy I grew up with,
who I ran into
while the show was on.
He said, "Hey!
I saw you on 'Mad About You.'
How did you think
of that crazy character?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I don't know.
I just kind of draw on
the people I knew in my life."
And he did not catch on that --
-Well, there you go.
There you go. Well, it's still
a loving tribute either way.
-Yeah, let's call it that.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, thanks for being here.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
-My pleasure.
-Hank Azaria.
"Hello Tomorrow!" is streaming
on Apple TV+,
and new episodes
premiering Fridays.
We'll be right back with
Diane Morgan.